we continue to learn more and more about
the group involved in that horrific
crash
just outside of town on thursday the
coroner's office identifying all five
victims tonight
sasha loftis joining us live with more
on the memories loved ones
are sharing sasha
brian i spoke with a close friend of tom
trogger tonight he was one of the five
cyclists killed in thursday's crash
he said tom was a star athlete known for
his success
nationally in triathlons his life was
stolen
far too soon but tom certainly made his
mark
it looks the deepest level that he's
gone but
i'm just grateful for the time we had
together maxwell jones is shattered
as he mourns for a man he knew and loved
he was a 57-year-old that had the energy
of a 20-year-old he was he was
relentless
tom trogger a husband father and friend
was one of five killed in this tragic
crash thursday
when a box truck hit a group of cyclists
along the u.s
95. any accident really sucks but this
one hurt
really deep just because it crosses so
many facets in life
aaron ray michael murray axoy ahmetz
gerard nieva also lost their lives
shaking the local cycling community to
its core
there's just a common bond among
cyclists in general
chris armstrong of the southern nevada
bicycle coalition
calls this a tragedy beyond
comprehension
but he hopes it can shed light on a
crucial issue
i just hope that from this we can
i guess bring awareness to you know the
dangers out there
from a cyclist perspective maxwell says
the entire crew was known for its safety
which makes this even more difficult you
get mad at the situation what the why it
happened
and then you get really scared because
that could have been
that could have been you know it could
have been anyone he wants those we've
lost
to know they will never be forgotten
whether they're watching we've got
them covered down here
now this investigation is still in its
very early stages
nhp says several others were also hurt
in thursday's crash
that included two other cyclists and the
person driving a safety car that was
going along with the group
now all three of those people are
expected to survive
of course stay with eight news now as
this crash investigation
continues to develop in the coming weeks
for now reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now